welcome to free code camp I've compared
your candy of Cody commanders and today
we're gonna learn all about set theory
and how we can use it to write some
really awesome code you're watching the
second video in our intro to logic
series if you haven't seen the first
video yet
intro to propositional logic you might
want to check that out
introduction to logic for programmers
video to set theory you'll find homework
in documentation at Cody commander's
comm slash logic dot PHP as programmers
and aspiring programmers the first
question you probably have is how is
that there you gonna help me with
programming
generally speaking web applications tend
to include a database server code and
client-side code to illustrate the
language relationship I will use an
analogy from my video on front end
versus back end web development in the
very front you'll find HTML and CSS
displaying data to the client aka the
user HTML is kind of like display
shelves at a shop and CSS is kind of
like the person who designed the shelves
in the very back we have a database this
is where we store data kind of like the
shops warehouse popular database
management systems include my sequel
MongoDB and Postgres database design is
arguably the most important part of your
applications design oftentimes it's
subversion of your application and poor
database management or implementation it
can slow down the entire development
process and it can even slow down your
entire application standing right in
front of our database we have alligator
server-side code woman she's kind of
like the store manager she could
communicate with the warehouse workers
also known as a database management
system she can also perform calculations
manipulations and had security clearance
to deal with sensitive and firm
she's opted in charge of the
applications logic and infrastructure
however she isn't the best at dealing
with customers so at the front of the
store
we have our customer service manager
JavaScript JavaScript works on the
client-side it can interact with the
HTML and CSS it could go in the front of
the house and talk to the designers and
the clients to make sure our display
shells are displayed in a user-friendly
manner she can also perform calculations
and manipulations on non-secure data
that is passed to her from aligator
server-side code woman set theory is the
foundation of database design a big part
of suicide code and application design
is interacting with the database so if
you become a logic rockstar it's gonna
be a whole lot easier for you to design
solid applications as a matter of fact
and computer programming we have data
types called arrays and objects these
data types are used for storing sets of
data these data sets are often directly
defined by our database tables so next
you might be wondering what is a set a
set is a collection of objects or
elements say you're designing a login
page you'll deal with sets of the user
data each user object may be a set of
data including user name email and
password users might be a set of user
objects in mathematics we say X is an
object and s is a set if the above
statement is true then X can either
belong to s or X cannot belong to s if
you remember back to my intro to
propositional logic video a proposition
is a statement that can either be true
or false the statement X is an element
of s can be true X or false
it could be true or it could be false
but it can't
both in mathematics if it's true we say
X is an element of s and it's denoted
just like you see and if X is not a
member of s we denote it like this
let's say that s is equal to all
possible even numbers you tell me are
the following statements true or false 2
is an element of s yes that is true
2 is an even number 3 is an element of s
nope 3 odd it's not even 7 is not an
element of s that's true sevens nodded
element of s because 7 is on how do you
define a set there's two ways to define
a set the first way is by extension and
we do that like so by putting values
into curly brackets we have F equals 2 4
6 and then we have x equals an empty set
there's no values in there and y equals
basically all even numbers starting at 2
with that dot dot dot means is that the
pattern is going to continue so why is
good equal to 4 6 8 10 12 and so on the
second way we can define a set is by
intention that's definition by
membership conditions so we could say X
is a member if X is an even number or in
the second example X is a member such
that X is an even number and it's also
greater than 0 s is going to equal the
set of all real counting numbers so tell
me are these statements true or false
1 is an element of s true 1000 is an
element of S 1000 is a real counting
number that is true negative 1000 is not
an element of s that is true as well X
such that x equals 3 X plus negative 3
equals 0
true because three plus negative three
equals zero X is less than zero or false
if x equals three that X must be greater
than zero so this is false X is greater
than two true because three yes indeed
is greater than two sets are equal if
they contain the exact same elements and
order doesn't matter so if s equals one
two and three and T equals two three and
one S&T are still equal sets and if sets
are equal remember by conditionals from
intro to propositional logic X is an
element of s if and only if X is an
element of t subsets if all of these
elements are contained in B then we say
a is a subset of B if a is a subset of B
and X is an element contain an A then X
has to also be an element contained in B
null set that means it's completely
empty
there's no values in it and we write it
like that Union okay look at that
diagram with a and B a union B X such
that X is an element of a or X is an
element of B if you look in the diagram
everything in a and everything in B is
going to be included in a union B X
belongs to a or it could belong to be
either one intersection intersection is
going to be this area I tried to make it
kind of purple combining the blue and
the pink X such
that X is an element of a and X is an
element of B a minus B X such that X is
an element of a and X is not an element
of B okay so if you look here this white
area that's not shaded that would be a
minus B that's the elements contained in
a that a Manby Cartesian products okay
just relax for a second and sit back and
just get the concept the Cartesian
product is a product of two sets say a
is a set which contains the values a B
and C and B is a set that contains the
values x and y we would write the
Cartesian product as a times B and it's
going to equal all possible ordered
pairs ordered pairs are when we take an
element in a and we match it with an
element in B so all possible ordered
pairs are gonna be a x a y bx b y CX and
CY most programming languages also have
some predefined functions that are gonna
help us find values within a set because
of that I'm gonna spare you all the
mathematical equations to calculate
these things most of them I think we
know what they need like we might have a
set of values and we want to find out
what's the biggest value in there that
would be finding the max value of the
set most programming languages have a
function for that if we want to find the
smallest value in a set we'll look for
the minimum most programming languages
have a function for that for search we
we could want to search for all kinds of
things and programming languages do tend
to have different predefined functions
where you might be searching for a
particular string say you want to return
any members of the
that that contain IMG you're looking for
image content or maybe you're looking
for specific value maybe you are looking
for the blog article that was posted on
a specific date so you're searching
through the dates for the one that
matches most programming languages have
predefined functions to handle all this
kind of stuff so let's do an example
okay you're making a game when the game
ends the high score list is displayed
there are ten spots on the high score
list right the code okay
so first let's do our logic thing let's
let T equal total score H equal high
scores and s equals show high scores
just in case the total score qualifies
we're gonna have a function written sub
where to add that score to the high
score list we want the code add score to
execute I've been only if total score is
an element on the high score list and
total score is going to be included as a
member on a high score list if and only
if the total score is greater than the
minimum score on the high score list the
smallest value there and regardless we
are going to display the high score list
somewhere we're gonna have a function
with code to display the top 10 scores
and if your total score qualifies you
will see your name and score there so
let's write it in PHP we have dollar
side total score equal to a function
that we have written out elsewhere which
calculates the current players total
score dollar sign high scores is going
to equal another function that we have
someplace else which fetches a probably
have a query there to go ahead go to the
database
get those 10 high scores and we'll store
it in dollar sign high scores dollar
sign men in PHP we do have a predefined
function to find the minimum value in a
set so dollar sign man is going to equal
the minimum of dollar sign high scores
if total score is greater than the
minimum then we're going to execute the
code to add the total score to the high
score list and no matter what in any
case we will display the high score list
for everybody to see if you made it as a
member on the high score list you will
see your name there if you did not you
will still see the chosen ones who did
make it on the high score list now let's
check it out in JavaScript we have bar
total score equaling that function to
calculate the current total score we
have our high scores equaling that
function to go the database and get the
high scores we have barmen equaling in
JavaScript we also have a predefined
function to find the minimum value in a
set and if total score is greater than
that minimum we're gonna execute the
code to add that total score to our high
score list and no matter what in any
case we're gonna go ahead and we're
gonna display the high score list for
the player to see thank you for watching
my video don't forget to go to coding
commander's comm slash logic dot PHP
with logic programming math the only way
you get better is by practice you watch
the video you learn the concept then you
have to apply it so please check out the
homework the last video I had a little
quiz for homework this time I have three
word problems if you have any questions
please feel free comment on this video I
will be checking the comments if you
complete the homework and you feel like
you want me to look it over you go ahead
uploaded ticket lab github wherever you
want tweet the link make sure to mention
me and free code camp I will try to get
to everybody if you do reach out and
it's been like a couple days you haven't
heard from me feel free to give me a
little nudge in the next video of the
intro to logic for computer program or
free code camp series I am going to
apply all the set theory we learned
today
test some actual sequel we're gonna
learn how to make awesome databases
using set theory thank you again for
watching my video and until next time
happy coding